this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 22nd of june the joint is
brought to you by stamps.com
when you're running a small business
every
second counts why take time out of your
day to go to the post office when you
could be using stamps.com instead make
mailing and shipping quick easy
and cost effective with stamps.com i've
been with stampscott.com now for close
to 12 years my wife and i are very happy
with it my wife it's easy for her she
weighs everything right here in the
[__] her office
puts it out puts the arm up on the
post office box and pimp
my package is out and delivered
stampscott.com gives you access to all
the post office ups shipping services
you need right from your computer save
up to 30
from usps rates and over 80 off ups
all you need is a regular computer and a
printer that's it no special supplies no
equipment you'll be up and running in
minutes so stop wasting your time and
start moving
start saving money when you use
stamps.com
to mail and ship
print official postage for any letter
any package anywhere anytime
no long-term commitment to contracts i'm
gonna hook you up with a promo deal a
four-week trial plus
free postage and a digital scale you
ready for this
it's free that's right just use promo
code joey go to stamps.com right now
click the microphone at the top of the
page and enter code joey and start
saving money and doing great for your
small or large business whatever it may
be the joint is also brought to you by
cbd lion
guys in the world of cbd
the lion is [__] king whether it's
the gummies
the delta a tincture the delta eight
gummies
the kinesiology tape the cream listen
cbd lion's got something for everybody
just a little bit of cbd tincture before
you go work out will make a huge
difference in your workouts but don't
take it from me go to
cbdline.com read the third party lab
results when you see something you like
boom
pressing code joey a joint and get 20
off your first order at c b b lion let's
get this party started i got jimmy
florentine in the house today
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
it's the what the [__] is the 22nd of
june
it's a beautiful wednesday my guest
today
is [__] rock knowledge here mr jimmy
florentine new jersey zone
what's going on taizen you know i would
i never knew when i was a kid reading
the back of these albums that it would
be useless
i always thought this information was
useless like why who who was the
original bass player on this album
and then later on it was i actually
needed that knowledge it paid off
who would have thought
it's really crazy how i read all the
liner notes and all the hotels they
stayed at like who the nerd
you know because van halen especially
always thanked the sheridans
if you look at the back of the van halen
now it always says
thanks to the sheridan so whatever so in
your mind you're like [__] when they
come to new york i'm going to stalk the
sheridans and that's exactly what
happened they stayed on 52nd and 7th one
year i was a bartender and i heard about
all this [__] they were doing so it's
kind of weird when you read all those
liner notes like when i don't know what
i was talking about the other day with
somebody and i said oh yeah phil mugg
i don't even know where that came name
came from
that's the guy from ufo you had a singer
from singapore ufo i don't even know
where i came from now what
what benefit by knowing the singer ufo
how does that could apply to daily life
it doesn't
it got like you know knowing the five
members of
elo or whatever the [__] it is but
when you're a kid you think that's
special
you read all that stuff and then one day
you grow up and now this is what you do
yeah i never thought it would pay off i
mean you know look if you were in a
heavy metal when you were younger there
wasn't a lot of girls that were into it
so
if you wanted to get laid
they didn't care that judas priest just
lost their drummer and they got a
temporary one for the tour they didn't
give a [__] you know but that's all you
wanted to talk i remember going
i remember going to a party i'm like you
know metallica might break up i'm like
blabbering to these girls like what do
you talk get away from me you weirdo
that's all i could talk about i didn't
care about anything else
you know so then you had a so
so you stayed in your room on friday and
saturday night and you're listening to
the record so you hung out with your guy
friends
no girl is going to come over because
you know screaming for vengeance just
came out your you and your friends are
all going to listen to him in someone's
basement
they got other things to do yeah girls
don't like that [__] right so you just
know like if you're in the metal you're
you're a loner you're a weirdo you're
socially awkward
you know because that's all you did and
then we grew mustaches i don't know if
you guys did this so we look older so
we're like 16 17 we all grew mustaches
so we can get sir beer so we go to
liquor store and like all right we won't
even ask right he's got a mustache so we
had these bad mustaches and wearing the
heavy metal so we were not getting laid
at all
with zero interest from any girl i just
remember putting mascara on my mustache
to make it look thicker that's a good
idea and then if you wanted a pool the
mascara ran like a [__] dodo
you know yeah yeah dog you use
everything you can i'm one of those
cubans every cuban is [__] hairy i'm
the only cuban that it takes a [__]
year and a half just to grow a mustache
so i would mascara it up on friday
nights to go out and get beer or
whatever
this is the [__] you do as a youngster
to get over guys and yeah girls don't
listen i i learned early on like 81 80.
i learned that you were not going to put
on hellbent for leather and pick up no
girl
and that's why i got into the b-52s
when the b-52 album came out that gave
all of us an out
there was a little heavy guitar so we
always had an out that quaalude music
when you go down down
with the quail you got down after you
got down four or five times with
quaaludes the last time you weren't
getting back up
you were just down right
down like what happened nothing the
quaaludes got me so
it's so weird how that's i still
remember specifically them and the cars
the cars yeah chicks loved candio
[__] you know i love candy honestly
for the i don't want you guys to think i
like candy oh because it picked up
chicks i'm not gonna i like that out it
just came out
june of it i just saw it it was the
anniversary
79.
probably around
saved my ass
you were not gonna pick up a chick
listen to leonard skinner
even if you put on [__] you know
the only song you had any
hope of getting laid at a party was love
hurts by nazareth and if you put love
hurts on it broke my [__] heart i had
to leave anyway as soon as love hurts
love hurts is our generations
every rose has its [__] thorn
both those songs i want to shoot myself
when i [__] hear him i like the guy
from poison but i've ever seen him i'm
gonna beat him with a [__] rose
because that song is [__] horrid
that's just then bon jovi came along i'm
sorry with uh
never say goodbye yeah that balance love
all that [__] you know that that was it
that was it that's the only savior you
had but if you put on
screaming for the helmet you were in no
danger if you put on the one before that
you know golden and lows all that [__]
point of no return whatever chicks
didn't like all that [__] no they
definitely didn't um
yeah the b-52s was big and then one bon
jovi see i grew my hair long my friends
from bands they go listen shave that bad
mustache off and grow your hair long you
look awful
so then i grew my hair long i shaved the
mustache off so whatever bon jovi did
with his hair i did with my hair so i'm
like okay he's got it this way i've got
it this way then i had the scruff kept
wing i had to scruff i did that and then
when bon jovi cut his hair in like 93
i'm like well then i got to cut my hair
okay yeah time to cut my hair so that i
did it but i and then so it still worked
for me once i grew that hair long it was
unbelievable i didn't have to listen to
the b-52s and pretend they're like
floccus eagles anymore no i didn't like
fly i saw flock the singles like the
go-go's the go-go's got a little [__]
but they didn't bust out the [__]
82-83 right the go goes with my lips are
sealed
that does me no [__] good you know
what i'm saying your lips are sealed
later
i got a long island iced tea with your
name on it
but it's [__] crazy how
you have then i had to go to discos
i remember still going to discos and
they weren't
top on my priority but that's where the
girls were
yeah well that's the thing you had to
dance i i went in the new wave for a
couple years you know when like the
flock of seagulls thompson twins all
that stuff hit mtv i'm like look i gotta
get some [__] so i
before i grew my hair long i went
through it lowe's hanging out like new
wave clubs new wave night wednesday
night dancing with girls and trying that
b52s all that stuff but
you know it got a little but then once
once metal hit mtv and all those hair
bands i said that's that's the look i'm
taking and then i started doing comedy
at the time and that's when like leave
bob levy was already headlining them
rich voss they're already headliners and
i would just do shows just because i had
like long blonde hair all these girls
would come up and talk to me especially
in pennsylvania it was great because
they were like five years behind to what
was really going on so my looks [__]
fit right in so these guys would take me
to like you know like oh my god the guys
you know all of a sudden all those
[__] around after the show i'm gonna
bring this guy in the road i wasn't
ready i had like three minutes they'll
just do ten i'll try
so uh they would just bring me just so
i'd attract girls but then sometimes i
would get laid and they would and they
were the headliners you know voss and
levy were doing an hour and killing i
was doing like seven minutes up front i
remember leaving one time and go says
girl did you see his set and you still
want to talk to him
it was fun it was my college years
because i didn't go to our way to
college so you know that's when you get
get all that [__] of your system so i
did it in you know
late 80s early 90s and then i started to
get my [__] together around 93 94. i cut
my hair oh my god i got to take this
stuff serious
yesterday or the day before
well let me tell you this story like
father's day i
i brought for jackson and on the way
down there on ozzie's boneyard invasion
of your privacy came on you know uh rap
the the main song from it uh lay it down
lay it down yeah and that was my album
in 85 and i'm like holy [__]
rap was already on their second album
before bon jovi's first album like
like rat hit before john bon jovi yeah
because bon jovi hit with runaway what
year was that that was like 82 but it
was it was 82 83 but it was a minor hit
it was a minor hit and then he had the
second album uh 7 800 degrees fahrenheit
that didn't do that well she don't know
me and there was one other song but that
wasn't big either until new jersey came
out and you give love a bad name
that was it you know and that that album
was what broke it was slippery when wet
i'm sorry slippery oh my that's it yeah
jersey's not bad but it's right that was
the fourth one but the third one was hit
the first two were just like yeah he's
like yeah it was all right but then that
you know slippery and wet came out and
that was it and then keith ross here
today was talking about a club where
zack wilde was the busboy
and bon jovi met his wife there
and that's where richie sambora
casanova's
it was probably on route 35 in
sayerville there was a bunch of there
was a place called mingles no another
one uh club 35 then there was art stocks
playpen that i worked that was the arts
the birch hill
i'm not sure which club it was but it
was
definitely was when richie sambora came
back and said
you got to listen to our [__] album
and he listened to the first three songs
and he knew that something was going to
happen with bon jovi and he just said
that this place was just legendary like
it was somewhere that was just [__]
bon jovi met his wife there she was the
bartender
you know just [__] zack wilde was a
bus boy yeah and zach zack grew up in
jackson and he is he married his you
know high school sweetheart she was from
jackson too zach grew up in jacksonville
he grew up in jackson new jersey yeah
wow yeah yeah it's not a starland
ballroom right that hasn't been like no
that was called modern times back then
there was a bunch of different names but
i don't think that was the place either
well you know how my brothers are ball
busters you know my brothers right
so i was telling you about the bon jovi
look so we're down in long beach island
at this place on vacation and i got the
long hair and we're at this bar like a
monday night it's packed and i went to
the bar to go get drinks and they some
girl goes is is that bon jovi over there
they thought and then of course my
brother's like yeah that's him they're
like that's bunch of he's like yeah
listen he's here on vacation don't
really bother him just go up say hi
don't make a big deal
and they're like oh god we could say hi
guys yeah go say hi to him but just be
you know be nice don't cause a commotion
next thing you know these girls are
coming over hey you bon jovi and i'm
like yeah you know i'm just thinking
they're gonna bust me a second the girl
thought it was bon jovi i started
talking to her then everybody else
started talking i had to leave the club
because it was getting so crazy like
bunch always over there he's over there
and i want to walk into a car when i'm
making out with her it's like i can't
believe i'm making out with jon bon jovi
i'm like yeah well you know what are you
gonna do
is that wrong that i did that no that's
fun but my brothers did that they go
that's bon jovi over there of course
and i just said yes and i'm thinking i
did at the comic ship one time in new
york city i had the long blonde hair
curly blonde hair one guy's like
are you the singer from led zeppelin i'm
like yeah but just keep it quiet
just keep it quiet i'm just here to see
some comedians they're like oh my god oh
my god and this is before cameras like
he didn't have his phone to take a
picture i go listen yeah just keep it
quiet man i'm just i love standup comedy
i'm in new york i didn't mean why i had
the same jersey i didn't have a brain i
didn't have a british accent or anything
that's like the story when i saw them
i sold the guy a membership to lamar
to what to the mafia right i even gave
him a membership yeah
he kept telling me i want to be in the
mob how do i do it i go that's easy i'll
make a call for you you have to fill an
application it's like two thousand
dollars initiation he gave it to me
and for months he would say did you hear
anything from them no
i haven't heard anything right
[Music]
almost like it's it's now it's good if
you don't hear anything right that means
they like you you're protected i mean i
this was 1995
he still calls me once a year
and somewhere in the conversation he'll
go hey man i've never heard from those
guys really and what do you say i don't
even uh just yeah just like that but you
know just the fact right he hasn't
didn't ask me for the two g's back right
so i don't care when he once he asked me
for the two g's back then i just hang up
on him but until then
until then i'll keep talking in 1995
it's over that seven year grace period
went off the [__] world right yeah
yeah
limitations is over yeah the statue of
limitation the stupidity because that's
as dumb as you can be
when he was counting the money out to me
i'm like no he's not
no he's not this has to stop somewhere
like when is he gonna go you thought you
had me haha and we'll laugh buy grandma
coke no
he gave me the two thousand and then we
hung out for like two months and he was
like man i can't wait to be in the mafia
i'm like jesus christ
one thing about that i'm really learning
about and i feel kind of embarrassed
about i came from northern new jersey
and we had the soap factory yeah we had
a
hole in your pants whatever hole in the
wall
yeah
you know and those and then i used to go
see sticky fingers someplace
there was like three rock clubs up north
but the more i talk to you the more i
talk to your brothers and [__] keith
ross
is great on ozzie boneyard and he drops
this knowledge it's like i'm embarrassed
i didn't where the [__] was i for part
of this new jersey
musical history this [__] metallica
and old bridge
you know like all this [__] that you
read about dios new jersey ain't he no
he's from like uh cortland new york oh i
like certainly like that's something
about dio in south jersey and
jersey just has such a [__] uh
history of music
like i had no idea even i just got a
book about crime in new jersey and
chronicles like the 50s and 60s
that was huge music like all those bands
were on labels out of jersey the black
bands and [__] i had no [__] idea
music was so
big in new jersey
well because when you were growing up
you stayed in your area you stayed up in
north bergen of new jersey i was in
central jersey we stayed here so i never
really i don't think i ever went to the
soul factory to see twisted sister or
nato's bands i didn't go to the hole in
the wall i had a bunch of clubs around
here
you know those those cover bands or you
know would would play the same clubs
so i would just stay here i would never
drive up there i'd go to the garden to
take the train and to see see a show but
so i think that's what you stayed in
your area we stayed you had enough stuff
going on there you'd have to come back
down here like somebody was telling me
they went to that place where they
played music on the water
that i went to see uh rod stewart in 84
my mom was telling you they only have it
open in the summertime
in the summertime we offer the
meadowlands
pnc
the garden and then
nassau coliseum i guess now the brooklyn
where the brooklyn yeah and there's
another place jones beach oh jones beach
on long island yeah a buddy of mine went
to see jewel two weeks ago stu final and
he said that [__] high tide came and
that the [__] shoes the sneakers were
all flooded they had to put their feet
up jules is up there playing the guitar
with galoshes on it
people get electrocuted and [__] like i
love that place like i went to so many
different venues yes we went to the
garden i'm very proud of that and i went
to the meadowlands to see
the jacksons and i went to philadelphia
and his feet but they had these little
spots like you know seeing like
aerosmith at the soap factory or saying
like
that group that class i told you about
when i went to passaic like i went to
see missing persons at the capitol
theater yeah
yeah our place was legendary that place
was good you know i went to see the
scorpions
and rainbow there like when i was really
young i didn't know who the f i just
went you know i liked that that damn i
like that [__] knucklehead richie
blackburn then he lost his mind have you
seen him lately
yeah i mean yeah he's
talk he does not look good
if you go to a [__] rainbow concert
bring a trick-or-treat [__] thing
like one of those pumpkins when you see
him you think it's a [__] halloween
thing
it's not good yeah he does some weird
kind of music i think i don't even know
what it's called with his wife
and he got rainbow back together but
with all like new players that no one
knew of he did like eight shows over in
europe and now he's back to doing his
his little thing [__] mustache yeah
that he [__] tightens up and
yeah i don't know if he looks like a
wizard yes
yes he looks like [__] he grew up
perfect to be what the [__] he wanted
i don't know what's going on i know the
place you talk about the fountain casino
that's what keith ross was talking about
because that was a big place in italy
he talks about that a lot that place
held three twisted sister would draw
3000 people on a monday night there it
was free admission
and they would do like three sets like
three hour sets
on a monday night it was insane
so i was 15 years old i was using my
brother's id he was 21. i was 15. it
didn't have a a picture on it back then
the jurors didn't have the picture it
was great one time i went to this liquor
store to go get beer because i had you
know and i put the idea on the camera
the woman's like you're not joe
florentine that's my older brother i go
yeah i am she goes no you're not like i
am sure you're not she goes i'm mrs
murphy and that was like joe's best
friend's mother and i'm like
should i put the beer back i just i just
left on the counter and walked out
i had no idea it was his best friend's
mom but i but i would get in at 15
you know because they didn't have a
picture so i didn't know i might just
show it they didn't bounce like wait a
minute you know they had no clue
so i was seeing shows when i was a
little kid it was great
that's good and then jones beach you
couldn't bring alcohol in there you can
only drink in the back like this vip
area you can't bring it back to your
seat because it's some state park
it's so so we'd have to get whenever i
went to jones beach you get those little
plane bottles like bacardi stick them in
your underwear make sure you wear tighty
whities that day don't ever wear boxers
that's a rookie move the tidy wires you
put them under your balls stick them and
stick like four bottles and just get
cokes the whole day yeah your diet coke
go in the bath and pour it in
see so if you get manscaped underwears
the new ones have a pouch
they could fit three [__] bottles
see manscape is always the head of the
[__] game sorry about that no because
even now you you're paying like 15 for a
mixed drink at a concert so bring that
stuff in
look i paid 20 for a frozen margarita
at
philadelphia oh yeah it's citizens back
i'm not going to fail at all it was well
worth the 20 buck for the margarita but
wow
yeah wow where has a [__] society
gone for margarita it was tasty
oh my god it was 95 degrees
i didn't get buzzed or anything i went
right through i even gave my daughter a
sip and i keep asking you she didn't get
drunk she's like no nothing happened
yeah yeah
you know it's just weird how
i was telling your brother
dan i go you know
led zeppelin played 45 years ago at in
1977 at the garden yeah the anniversary
was a couple days ago
and the tickets were 7.50 to 12.50
7.50 to 12.50 and
i'm looking at paul mccarthy the other
day at the meadowlands aka metlife
stadium
and he wanted a thousand dollars for
those [__] tickets for like decent
tickets
to see paul mccartney and bon jovi sing
happy birthday like i want to hear happy
birthday again i don't ever want to hear
happy birthday at a [__] concert now
and people singing happy birthday for
[__] paul yeah he's 80 years old no
more birthdays happy birthday paul but i
ain't saying that you know i'm done you
know that bruce springsteen showed yeah
he played [__] what's that song get
back glory days to his own song oh okay
he did i'm not paying a thousand bucks
to hit glory days or [__] get back or
whatever hey jude i don't want to hear
that [__] i want to hear some [__]
you know i don't know some john lennon
music i don't [__] though do
something a thousand dollars yeah i mean
those uh you know
that's what they sell now you know
ticket messages did a thing where
they're not charging you an extra fee
they're trying to compete with the the
other you know scalpers and all the
other online places so ticketmaster if
you're gonna buy a ticket like two hours
before a show you're not going to get
that 60
convenience fee and if you're buying
four tickets that's 240 extra dollars so
they waived that which is great so
they're trying to bring the competition
down you know like so these other venues
will do with stubhub and vivid seats
there's a million of them
it's just crazy where the price of you
know
i think how all the like i told your
brother i go you know i went to see rod
stewart i went to see all these bands
because
i'm either going to take this twenty
dollars and blow it on cocaine or i
might as well see kenny rogers let me
just see what he's about it doesn't
matter let me see what nazareth is about
yeah now
you can't do that
you know i was telling you like i'm not
paying
i i saw sammy hagar 20 years ago i kind
of liked them people were spitting at
him in philly i didn't know what to
think
but it's like i'm not paying 600 bucks
for those tickets i love the art of live
concerts you know i love all that [__]
it's just such a rush
but the 600 paycheck just kills me i
went online the other day to look at
raging against some machine tickets
wow yeah wow five nights at the garden
yeah there's like single tickets for
like 350 bucks
all over the place but yeah
so
you know it's a matter of you're gonna
pay you bring two when i saw billy joel
at the garden you know a couple months
ago and
you know two tickets was like
seven hundred and ten dollars for the
two with taxes and everything else so i
got him late but i was like all right
whatever i mean i want to see him once
but it was like 710 bucks for the two
that's how to get them on you know 710
bucks that's two car payments yeah it
was like 360 355 attack two [__] car
payments you know and you go yeah i like
these bands like i told you i'm going to
see two bands i want to see jelly roll
because he'll leave tickets for me and i
could really get into that and i'm going
to see allison chains i finally want to
go
see allison chains at pnc over here i'd
like to go to camden too you know
but those days just
i i kind of like fleetwood mac let's go
see i don't know if the chick was on
tour or something but what would stop me
is as soon as i went
for that ticket that 400 ticket how was
an 18 year old gonna go to a concert
again i moved here so my daughter could
kind of have
the same childhood like had growing up
but you can't even you know you can't
even fathom these kids gonna have to rob
a bank
to go see [__] uh they're gonna have
to rob a bank yeah between the 14 how
much is the bus to the city though 30
bucks
yes 30 round trip 15 each way yeah
and that's not bad because if you drive
you're dropping 40 with the price of gas
and the the tolls 16 at the the tall at
the lincoln tunnel then also the
turnpike tolls
wow
it's gotten [__] crazy yeah well the
ticket price will go down as soon as the
demand you know when people aren't
paying 400 bucks they'll lower it to 300
the lower to 200 so all that stuff's
going to go down as the economy tightens
up so
you know that all of a sudden these
bands think they're going to get 450 for
a ticket
you know and then the people reselling
them on those secondary markets all that
money's going to go way down soon you
know we went to the giant game and that
game was brilliant
in more ways than one just going to
phillies against the giants
and i tell you what was the most
brilliant part of the day
i didn't feel gouged over the 70 ticket
i didn't feel guys you know
the the waters were five you know again
that's not bad they're seven there's ten
dollar waters you know
the food was good it was cheap sausage
sandwiches
i kind of am i a philly fan of the of
the team i don't know anything about
them
but the [__] feeling i had and i
didn't feel out you know
if i i know if i go to a uh
yankee game it's going to cost me
double that probably it's going to cost
you 50 to 75 just to park
close and you want to park close it's in
a bad neighborhood
so yeah if you want to get real close
it's going to be 75.
if you want to get kind of close it's
just 50. yeah stay sandwiched to 30 at
the [__] yankee stadium they're
delicious
i heard their [__] five stars like
you know they got you you're there you
know but yeah again
when i was a kid i just [__] wake up
today and go dog you know the mets are
playing at 1 30. really
let me call my brother and see if he can
drive us or not we'll just go to pert
damn boy that's where you go you go to
perth and
switch that [__] uh because my friend
went the other day go to perth damn boy
switch it
whether in the city and it takes you
right to the [__] met game
all right the citi field yeah the city
field but it's like
again for me i knew for five dollars i'd
get into a mec game
or a yankee game you could stub your way
in on a tuesday who's that a [__]
mech game on a third you know the mech
games get packed like anything else on
the weekends people want to take their
kids and [__] you know met game on a
tuesday yank game on a tuesday [__]
[__]
word nick game on a tuesday that was my
favorite those nick tickets for 15 bucks
bro
try to get a nick ticket for 15 you got
to blow the whole [__] team
for 15 [__] dollars well see and what
we used to do is we always get tickets
out front so you always look for someone
at the last minute someone couldn't come
right they'll come with five all of a
sudden two people said we can't come we
have an emergency so you look for that
sucker that guy that's not a scalper you
know what i mean like just walking and
you're waiting
i got tickets how much i just want to
get rid of them can you give me you know
fifty dollars more each year no but
you're not gonna sell them up there i go
you might get arrested if you go up
there because there's cops all over you
can't be scalping tickets all right just
give me just give me the face value
beautiful
so you always look for those guys you
don't look for the professional guys and
then as as it goes on you go to you know
the first inning second inning they're
basically giving them away if you want
to hang that long the problem is if you
have someone with you that's panicking
thinks they're not going to get in then
you got to get them in advance yeah i'm
too old to panic
like i want to know i'm going like i did
i did that 100 times like let's just go
see what happens right let's just go see
what happens all of a sudden you're
watching ac dc and def leppard you know
let's just go see
but that's what you do when you're 15.
yeah you don't care you're like all
right we'll just go drink at a bar then
we'll go to beefsteak charlie's across
from the garden i don't want to go there
and argue with people like i remember i
went to philly one time and we went like
12th roll
and before we got in my buddy was
talking something awesome he came back
with six rows center for black sabbath
with deal and i'm like how the [__] did
you do you know like you had we had
tickets what possessed you to negotiate
with somebody for six rows better
but there's guys that are really good at
i used to break their balls too but i
don't want to be out there arguing with
nobody now i just want to walk and then
yeah enjoy the [__] game and whatnot
but they kill you at these games i
always think about the american family
i all like my friend said he paid a
thousand dollars to go from
laguardia to oklahoma city
a thousand dollars to go to oklahoma
jesus christ no yeah i mean uh yeah yeah
i was like it's like nine i was i'm
booking flights for the fall right now
which i never did
and they're like you know to go to
dallas is like 780
from newark but if you fly at six in the
morning it's like five
five ten like that's your options now
they just complete like the airline
screw trying to make as much money as
possible before they have to bring down
the prices when people start
flying they're already down like three
percent
you're traveling like in the last month
so people are feeling it they're not
paying friggin you know 900 a ticket i'm
trying to go to knoxville i'm going to
pay 909
for not even a round trip with a layover
so i just booked that a legionnaire
they they do flights it's like it's uh
79 each way
to knoxville direct flight 160. why is
united charging 909.
and a legion's charge of 160. because a
legion's [__] engine is kind of loose
well yeah and the landing gear is all
[__] up
[Laughter]
so it's like you're paying 79. what time
am i going to get there
well i got i got i got both flights
booked so i got one united i used my
miles and then i got the allegionaire
one so if the legionnaire because
there's only one flight out that day
they only fly to knoxville on tuesdays
and fridays
you know so if there's one flight out so
if that flight doesn't go you're [__]
so i started my united flight i'm like
i'll just figure it out that day i'll
cancel the other one and where the [__]
is the lion where does it fly i don't
know if they fly into newark they got
some flights out of newark
and where do they go well one's going to
knoxville we're looking at knoxville
so i'm taking it yeah it's like 70. it's
160 bucks round trip compared to 908
dollars we united and i got a connecting
flight in chicago
i got to connect that to chicago too i
don't know about a lion for seventy nine
dollars
you know you might get the wright
brothers i figured i drove with so many
drunk drivers over the year and i lived
so far so if you know i'm figuring i'm
going to make it with a legionaire at
least the guy's going to be sober you
get to the [__] airport you see the
guy spinning the [__] thing in front
we'll get this plane no time you see him
duct tape and the wing and [__] like
major league yeah no this is not gonna
[__] work
i'm always weary of those things i'm
always weary of flying but when i see a
cheap flight i'm like what the [__] are
they doing
are we even gonna get there
well yeah like i you know i mean rarely
i usually just fly united like spirit
i'm like you know i can't get on one of
those planes oh it just bothers me just
yeah i think spirit i flew them years
ago and they had sirius
one of those flights were like a shitty
airline but they had sirius xm right
and i'll never forget i got on their
stone to the gills and i was listening
to like
disco something and it was so [__]
good the story is like we're gonna land
it was one of those atlanta flights okay
they have a special thing that flies to
a land not no more this had to be 20
years ago
but i'm always weary of spirit
but the way that [__] uh american
delta and all these other airlines have
been
southwest has been killing [__]
lately
killing people delays and stuff these
[__] advertise the summer sale
i saw it now let me tell you something
about southwest i enjoyed them if you're
gonna fly two hours unless
vegas lax
you know kennedy [__] buffalo
whatever newark buffalo it's an hour to
southwest if somebody's allergic to
peanuts you don't get peanuts for an
hour you're not gonna [__] die you
know what i'm saying so
it's
southwest put an ad out
for 49 and then three days later they
cancelled
[__] summer routes
so after they took everybody's [__]
money you know
this [__] concerns the [__] out of me as
you know i got to take a plane thursday
to south carolina to meet burt and those
guys yeah and i swear to god if i get to
[__] newark and they start that [__]
of a seven hour delay i'm not going
i'm not going i'll get in my car and
meet them in bristol tennessee
i might as well do that
i'm petrified about flying out of dallas
monday
but after a four night where you lay
your [__] soul on the stage right i'm
gonna get to the [__] airport monday
morning they're gonna go your flight's
delayed till two in the afternoon i'm
let me tell you something
i don't like dallas that much that's
what kennedy got shot i'm not a big
[__] fan no dallas nah they always
gotta strike with me as soon as i land
in dallas i can smell the gunpowder i
still smell the [__] gum bottle by
the trees and [__] whatever the [__]
yeah the grassy no
i don't you know
and dallas is an airport that if you're
not in shape
you're going to die
if you oh
yeah chicago detroit detroit
atlanta is a [__] detroit they
make you walk under the [__] airport
with the lights and [__] yeah i know you
yeah like seven in the morning you think
you're in the [__] twilight zone i'm
gonna see some matching cabin
from [__] uh whatever no all those
airports so dallas the only good thing
about dallas is you're eating good all
day
they got the barbecue they got the steak
house and dollars you get a little
massage i think you take a shower in
dallas
and
probably the hottest chicks in the
country in dallas i think yeah well
houston too i like all
you know what as a kid when you're young
you go like yeah there's a lot of hot
chicks down there i gotta tell you
something
there's a lot of hot chicks everywhere
there's a lot of i went to the osteria
last tuesday
i was blown the [__] away i'm a married
dude i'm old i'm not gonna hit on
somebody young what am i gonna you just
scar him when you show him that [__]
i was looking at my dick the other day
before i wanted to show it looks like an
aardvark now really it looks like an odd
bark the way the the head the turtleneck
the uncircumcised skin rolls in there
right
i wouldn't show that to anybody i didn't
know you were uncircumcised yeah oh yeah
so it's definitely gonna so it won't
come it's almost like it won't come out
of its shell no you're like a shy turtle
yeah you're dead it's kind of weird you
gotta pull the skin back
i used to hide [__] in there grams of
blow and stuff in the skin
[__] tremendous
pool cleaner
but it's [__] crazy how i went to the
osteria the other night i went to george
and i go george you got to start coming
down here look at all these beautiful
women over 40.
where'd we go uh i went somewhere last
week and i'm like
there's great looking women everywhere
now there's always going to be a great
looking woman who's going to be bad
looking
but there's great looking [__] women
down here in jersey i know i just
remember going to dallas for the first
time you know 15 20 years ago and then
all of a sudden there was hot women and
they were nice to you you know new
jersey they're not nice to you you know
what i mean like you could barely get
hello hi how are you they're just like
what are you i'm married i'm like i just
said hello but there they were nice and
they almost you almost take it the wrong
way like this chicks into me like no
that's just the way they are
so i just couldn't believe they were hot
and nice
me too houston was the one place that
always shocked me the south has always
shocked me how women will talk to you
and
you know when you're young you're like
[__] why is she talking to me do i
have a chance then you figure it out you
don't have a chance with everybody
people are just [__] nice sometimes
how many times did you try to hit on a
woman like and you got the wrong idea
and she wasn't interested like you go to
kiss her and she's like no no no i'm
just
you ever get that where she just turns
her head
and you feel like a piece of [__]
afterwards
it's been 30 years 25 years right yeah
and you got
my first girlfriend like six seventh
grade she broke up me because she said i
didn't know how to kiss
so i said listen man don't say anything
to anybody let's just say we broke up
whatever she was yeah i'm not going to
say anything don't worry about it the
next day she showed the whole school
it's really funny you know whenever this
guy he doesn't have a cash i [__] got
she got pounded by that
she wanted she didn't you know how to
swap spit
i didn't know it
was just a simple
i had no idea you're seventh grade i was
i didn't even jerk off yet so i had no
clue god i didn't know how to kiss i
didn't know what it was
i didn't want my tongue in some weird
girls and she and she was like the
hottest chick in the town i couldn't
believe it she was a year older than me
i'm like man it's unbelievable
it's you know like after like a month i
got i'm done with this guy
i think i said let's go meet at the
swings you know that was probably a bad
move
i'll meet you by the way swings you know
i mean when i was like in the first
grade in new york city there was a girl
debbie dominguez they used to show me a
tits for a quarter
in the first grade it's a good deal she
used to get a 45 single right pull up
her shirt and get the single and put the
whole right and put the nipple in the
first grade i still think about this
like where is this crazy [__] she used
to show it to me under the monkey bars
and she had like three brothers that
were gorillas the dominguez brothers and
i were like why are you showing me a
ditch give me a quarter i used to call
her every day
she wanted those little things of orange
juice and a hot dog gordon [__] 1968
that's great yeah yeah
you know
again back to
listening to like music that's like old
that same song lay it down i'm driving
with my wife my door's the back i'm
looking out the window and i'm just
listening to the lyrics
and before they break into a solo they
go like you know
give me a chance to prove myself in the
sack or whatever the [__] the guy says
and i'm thinking about like that album
came out when basically i was 21 years
old
and you're [__] very you don't know
where you land you don't know how to act
you know i'll never forget being at a
bar in carbondale colorado
i'm 21 years old
and i'm talking to two guys that i lived
with one guy and the other guy's name
was big ad he was like a [__]
six foot five guy that got his dick
sucked every day
like he had like a two foot deck he was
like a beginning porno guy right he
didn't know how to get into porno i'm
dead serious with you
and i remember i was there with him and
he's like joey talk to this girl she
wants to talk to him we were talking and
she's like i sell like
whatever i have a van myself i don't
know what she sold
and i still remember to this day like
looking at him going hey
why don't we go to the van i'll show you
what i'm about or something and she was
like ill
and she swung away from me and i'm like
where did that come from like what am i
going to do
in a vacuum van
right like i was that naive and that
fool it like to this day i think about
that like i said something to her in a
very wrong sexual you know but it was
1983 what the [__] nobody cared at that
time you could grab a woman by the hair
and stick your dick in here nobody said
nothing to you these people were savages
in the 80s
they were savages in the 80s oh yeah if
louis c.k was whacking off in front of
you in 2020 think of what we were doing
in the [__] 80s so he didn't know i
was just a kid and i didn't sexually
harass her not like i just she was like
talking to me and she was cute and she
was a little older
and i was like hey why don't we just go
in the van or something why don't we go
and she just looked at me like i was ted
bundy she's like that's not gonna happen
and then said something to big ed big
ass like hey man
i don't know she left mad or i don't
know what she has a boyfriend or
whatever but it was just
but then you do that and then
maybe five years later i'm at my house
and i want to snort some coke
and boulder and i go to a party and it's
like you know the the party's ending i
could catch
some dealers that uh and there was a
girl downstairs shooting pool
and we shot like two rounds of pool
and she goes do you want to play for
money and i go
my money's going to cocaine and she goes
why don't we just do this
if i win you suck my [__] or something
and if you win you eat my i don't know
what the [__] was going on
and i remember that i beat it
and that we fooled around
and then she got dressed and goes i
gotta go home my husband's waiting on me
the kid's got to go to school
i'll never forget that
i don't know what her name was the mom
of the year yeah i don't know what her
name was i don't know
you know when you think of all those
things you're like what the [__]
happened and how fast did this light
move
no i know man my first girlfriend um
broke up me because i used saran wrap
instead of a condom on her
that's not good
it's not good that's not good that's not
good it was like the third time i ever
had sex i was a virgin with this girl or
whatever it was like my third time and
i never condom we're fooling around her
parents house it was like two in the
morning they were sleeping
and she's like i didn't think we're
gonna have sex i didn't have one on me
[__] you don't have a condom like hold
on i ran up in her her kitchen naked
looking for a condom in the kitchen like
her parents are gonna have one in one of
the drawers you know
and i was looking around out of my mind
i had a hard on [__] testosterone
just turned 18
and then i found a saran wrap i just
ripped it off and i was just and i went
down it was dark so she didn't know i'm
trying to work it in and obviously you
know it needs some lubrication and then
she turned the light on she's like what
is that oh my god saran wrap like you
[__] [__] we started arguing the
parents woke up lights went on
and then like two days later she broke
up me she was so disgusted
i used to sit outside of her house and
wait for her to come home
begging to take me back
again a condom made out of saran wrap
that's american ingenuity i had to hold
it at the same time smart people [__]
yeah i mean i got to figure out
something i'm like i need something
you're the king of improvisation cause
it would have it would have worked if it
would have went in it would have worked
yeah i just have to hold it at the base
but i'll tell you how i know it would
have worked
all those you know we had a bunch of
i think on the church we had a bunch of
discussions about
the massage parlors in north hollywood
and i always knew somebody like the
the one guy went on rogan
the guy that painted facebook
headquarters
okay uh chow or show he went on there
and said he went to a massage problem
the chick had to be 40. she ate his
[__] she was although she was older
than 40. she was like 15.
i don't know he said he said he went in
there and he goes what when is the young
girl available and the girl was like no
young girl today it's me and he goes how
bad could it be because she picked up my
dick and started eating my ass for
openers you
know so for openers when somebody opens
with an eating ass yeah they're a savage
they just bypassed the whole situation
so
i heard different stories and there was
a guy that used to go to jiu jitsu with
me that used to basically go to
jiu-jitsu change and then walk right
over
to the massage parlor like maybe seven
doors down
and he told me that and there because if
they get raided they can't have the
condoms on premises
it's already prostitution but they have
tons of [__] saran wrap and boxes of
rubber bands and that's what they were
doing they would do they would put saran
wrap on your dick a rubber band and a
chinese chick or japanese or korean or
whatever vietnamese or die i don't want
to insult my body they would suck your
dick with the saran wrap on and then the
rubber bands on the bottom they just
pull it out and throw it away i had a
couple guys tell me that they went to
all those north hollywood they were
disgusting
those things i don't know how people do
it i don't want a massage that bad i
walked into like one or two of them that
were kind of weird like you're like
and then my buddy turned me on to a good
massage place that you could just you
know you could do whatever you wanted to
there was guys
it was guys and one asian chick rubbing
you down but the rest of those places
i got caught in one of those things one
time in michigan i just
you know i was green i was a feature act
it was like maybe my first weekend as a
feature act and my shoulder was stuck
i'm driving you know i had to drive 22
hours my shoulder got stuck and i walked
into one of those
places in michigan and the chick at the
door was lucy lujack
and i didn't know what was going on
she's like come in the back take off all
your clothes i go what i have to take
off my clothes my shoulder
she's going to take off all your clothes
like okay i took off my clothes dawg she
sent the c team in that [__]
she greeted you but then she said oh
yeah yeah they always put the good
looking one out front and then they said
they send the scrubs in and i just
picked up 250
from doing five shows
in michigan that's what you get you know
and i'm driving back i'm trying to make
ends meet and she's rubbing my shoulder
and i'm sitting there like what the [__]
is next and she stopped and she goes for
40. i give you a hundred job and i'm
like you have no [__] like forty
dollars
maybe maybe a dollar or two
for forty hours i can do it myself plus
i'm broke
i gotta eat those subway sandwiches
those veggies oh yeah i ran the [__] out
of there when that lady i don't want
anybody [__] whacking me off i'm too
old i have to get 21. i don't want a
[__] hand job from anybody
the first time my friend went in one i
was like how was it because i was like i
don't know if i want to go in there he
goes he goes i was done in seven
mississippi
you know how do you say when you play
for one mississippi two mississippi goes
out
i counted a seven mississippi and i came
i'm like that doesn't seem like it's
worth it then
he paid for it
you know how bad i would feel if i paid
a woman for sex
and i came like in two minutes like i
usually do it's no nothing's gonna
change whether you're wonder woman or
you still can't control light after all
these years she'll be chick-fil-a
right
you can breathe and close your eyes and
[__]
it's very hit and miss but usually i'm a
minute and a half
if i really focus and think i can't do
it in the morning no more i get all
rushed up and anxiety really but if i
really focus and take my time i'm okay i
could do you know what about when you
used to do coke back in the day because
usually you could [__] for hours on coke
i never did coke so i don't know
load came fast that came fast came on
the tits right
and then you do a little bit more coke
[__]
right and you're up all night so it's
not like there's any pressure to get but
then your dick dies
then like i was in situations were
horrible one night i was doing i was
gonna have a threesome never had a
threesome in my life i'm in miami it's a
chubby chick and a good looking chick
and then i come back
the chubby chick takes off her clothes
i'm all coked up i'm watching [__]
one of those late night talk shows it's
a tuesday night they swap and spit
they're eating their [__] and they're
like join in guess what i got dead deck
my dick is a turtle my dick already went
into the skin the only thing that's out
there is the wings
don't you just see me sitting here i
mean if i was involved
i would if i could be involved they kept
coming over don't you want to join in
no and then after the night and we
passed out i went to peel like eight in
the morning also i had like a two foot
dick and i'm trying to wake up the two
girls let's do it
that go away go away it's too late we're
tired we got to go to the dentist yeah
you got to capitalize on that moment
yeah
i won't no i've never been good at that
[__] you know
i know people who brag they go for two
hours and
they went all night they didn't sleep i
think that happened to me one time when
i was 19. right she was 27 so i wasn't
navigating the ship
it was her ship she knew what she was
doing i didn't yeah and she kept me up
all night that's when she put the sponge
in the [__]
remember in the 80s it was 83 so this
chick had her it wasn't a diaphragm oh
yeah
yeah yeah i remember that thing yeah a
little sponge and when they flew out and
just [__]
did you ever hit the sponge
i'm not sure you know i was too young
and [__] i was [__] you needed
someone like you had a 27 year old when
i was like 20 i had a 38 year old
she would rock our world she went
through all of our friends all my
friends did she just yeah sat separate
times or whatever like that i'm like
this woman taught us
i never saw a woman on all fours before
in my life i'm like this is [__]
awesome she's walking around naked i'm
like holy [__] that's crazy this uh girl
but she she taught me the ropes i'm sure
that 27 year old did too she filled in
some holes okay there was a couple of
holes in my game
it was amazing because i was 19 she was
and she had a sister tia they were from
milwaukee and they were my neighbors in
aspen when i first moved to
uh
whatever the [__] basalt holland hills
and she used to cut my hair
and one day i'm sitting and she's
cutting my hair we were friends already
and one thing led to another and she
goes just what's going on with you do
you have a girlfriend i go not yet i got
a crush on you and i put
my hand up her skirt
and she took my hand out she didn't say
no she goes you want it that way she
goes i'll tell you what i kind of like
you too she goes but i can't [__] you
are you my neighbor
she goes you're moving out in 11 days
then we can have an affair i swear to
god
i moved out july first of 83 she was at
my house july set
with brie cheese and apples and a
blanket and i'm like what the [__] is
brie cheese right and wine yeah yeah and
i'm a [__] animal from jersey i just
wanted to hit her in the head with the
glass wine and [__] her and eat a [__]
that's it
and we're on the grass in the middle of
snowmass village with like a real
[__]
a real picnic like i've never been in a
picnic
and all i want to do is [__] and she
wants to eat brie cheese and rub it on
an apple and drink wine
ask me about the fruitiness of the wine
and i i just i listen i gotta [__] you
like i can't take this and she's like
okay we went back to the house we just
did in the shower she had the hairiest
[__] i ever saw so this is how when
you're 18 you you do creepy things but
you don't remember until
when you moved back to jersey
so
she rocked my world so hard that
afternoon guys like she came over like
at one
and she left like at four and it was
like
like i was blown the [__] away it was
like seeing somebody for the like
sabbath for the first time right
my mouth was wide the [__] open and
i took a shower and i got my head
together i smoked some pot and i was
like damn it
i'm going to get more that [__] guys
i walked from snowmass village because i
just had so much energy
i wanted a [__] so bad i hitchhiked
down to snow mess he was going to aspen
i was going to basalt i walked the
[__] basalt i think somebody picked
me up towards the end
she got off she worked at the grog shop
at aspen a wine store and she got off
for work at like nine it took like maybe
30 minutes i i'll never forget i was
sitting in the weeds
on a chair when she pulled up to the
grog shop
and i'm like i gotta hit this again
because i didn't give you my best show
right like you [__] walk me out
and that was the night i stayed up with
her all night then i started dating her
we dated till about and she wanted me to
go to a rocky horror picture show
yeah that's where you lost me yeah like
i already won yeah i already ate your
ass yeah you already wanted a picnic
with you i'm not going anywhere else i
wanted a couple picnics with this [__]
you didn't know she was a white chick
that's what they like to do yeah i know
they like that coin
rub your feet and all that she was gonna
make a sandwich and sit there no free
cheese and apples that was it that was
it okay
yeah we didn't you didn't drink wine
then i didn't even know what the [__]
was i drink a bottle of wine northbrook
and i robbed from albertsons that a half
gallon that julio gallows oh yeah that
stuff yeah i had a headache for four
[__] days oh yes the worst [__] but
you always had to have it just in case
you had girls over keep the wine
just have one because
no no chick wants to drink bud cans
you know that's all we drank was
budweiser
coke
whatever you have but it's always good
to have that wine what did i give you i
got [__] mcgregor whiskey it tastes
like ass but it don't matter
the worst was if you were metalhead and
you got a girl back you you know you
wanted to put on some music in the
background but you know you have all
heavy metal [__] so it's
you know they might i would put i'm like
well let me i remember putting ozzy on
like goodbye to romance that was a slow
song it's a good jam yeah i know but it
was like i didn't have anything oh
there's something i went out and bought
that chard album yeah that first chard a
almost [__] that was a close fire
fire
like a madonna i forgot what madonna won
the first mcdonald's maybe yeah just
have those two in the collection my
friends would make fun of me like you
got chardonnay what are you gay i'm like
no i go i need this i got [__] iron
maiden doesn't have any ballads i can't
put [__] the trooper on
when this chick trying to get her in the
mood so i throw that on so i always had
those two
that shot a album was [__] phenomenal
like marianna rivera oh the first two
chade albums are [__] classic classic
you have the first one
i probably still probably still yeah we
got to borrow for the album of the week
that's good
that's a great [__] album that that
i like shodday i even like i just got a
greatest hit so i downloaded on
something
the greatest hits isn't bad just
something different to listen to in the
gym yeah yeah [__] like that you can't
lose the sabbath every [__] i don't know
if i can work out to shardato nah but
when you're on a plane yeah yeah
something yeah you want to be mel yeah
i'll throw some goofy [__] on every once
in a while you got any dates coming up
tarzan um
yeah when the july 2nd pottawatta
potawatoma casino in
milwaukee wisconsin i'm there and then
july seven through night side splitters
in tampa and then the improv in tampa on
sunday uh july 10th where are you at
were you in albany wednesday night
what thursday yeah i will be tonight
yeah that's [__] great man yes i'm
doing that and then my podcast everybody
is awful every monday i do patreon do
three extra podcasts a week on my
patreon so
everybody's awful out every monday and
join the patreon well you got to see the
[__] neighbors we didn't have to zoom
this time
yeah i know it was great i'm like i
could do this podcast it's right around
the corner right
from the corner it was at 11 o'clock i
left at 10 58. that's beautiful [__]
perfect
but i'm excited about the bird tour i'll
see you [__] in bristol
i don't know south carolina mississippi
i'm excited i saw i saw the videos he's
doing a great job now bert's great man
he knows he's doing a great job so uh
hopefully i'll see you [__] out
there and that's it i want to thank
jimmy for coming on i want to thank you
[__] for supporting us and now
for a word for my [__] sponsors
jack
all right you bad [__] i want
to thank jimmy plus i want to thank you
guys i'm excited about going on the road
so we won't be having a podcast on
monday we'll be back next wednesday
[__] but listen
in the meanwhile the joint is brought to
you by stamps.com
i love stamps.com regardless of whether
you got a business with 100 employees or
business with three employees why take
time out of your day to go to a post
office when you can just do everything
from your office or home or wherever you
send packages from make mailing and
shipping quick easy and cost effective
listen to that word cost effective
that's my favorite [__] word it's
easy
anybody could do it if i could do it you
could do it stamp.com gives you access
to all post office and ups shipping
services
save up to 30 off on usps rates and over
80 on ups rates all you need
is your regular computer and printer no
special supplies no genies no wizards
you'll be up and running in minutes so
stop wasting time and start saving some
guidance when you go to stamps.com to
mail and ship this the only way to go
sign up with promo code joey j-o-e-y
and get a four-week trial plus free
postage and a digital scale no long-term
commitments just go to stamps.com right
now click on the microphone at the top
of the page and then to code joey you're
going to enter a world of savings and
your business is going to be that much
better
stamps.com code joey j-o-e-y the joint
is also brought to you by cbd lion
like i've said it for the last three
years when you're working with cbd line
you'll know it i don't care if you're a
lifter or
a jiu jitsu i don't give you got a
[__] pogo stick we all get injuries
from time to time
we slip whatever you can rub the cream
on your muscles the gummies to help you
relax at night they got melatonin i mean
they got a delta eight gummies i'm gonna
save you 20 right off the bat you're
going to be [__] looking out the
window going why do i hear chinese music
that's what i'm talking about with cbd
lion whether it's the kinesiology tape
the bat balls the cream i mean listen
they come at you from every direction
they leave no
stone unturned go to cbd cbdline.com
right now pressing code joey or join and
get 20
off
your first [__] order it's that
simple
i want to thank stamps.com and i want to
thank cbd lion
i want to thank manscape
i want to thank
the freeze pipe and i want to thank
jimmy florentine for coming in house
today
and making my life a lot [__] easy i
love your [__] i'll either see
you
thursday friday saturday or sunday on
the birth door if not i'll be back next
wednesday stay black uncle joey loves
you
and i'll see you then